auch heiko kempken direkt vor die presse
hallo und herzlich willkommen meine
damen und herren jetzt nur ein drittel
mit millionär ist meine damen und herren
ihre persönlichen und wittlage blinde
ein während helfer bevor ich jetzt mit
der hund vor anfang erstmal die ganze
story wie das überhaupt alles zustande
kamen und zwar bin ich mit macht und ja
ich bin macht wir haben uns gestern
gedacht dass man eine runde spazieren
gehen und irgendwie mir da noch die idee
gekommen dass nach amsterdam fahren und
wenn der eine oder andere weise damit
übernahmen wirklich von köln und
zweieinhalb stunden entfernt deswegen
haben wir ganz schnell gegoogelt
irgendwie nach irgendwelchen und helfen
haben halt hier in dem euro erhält
europe de l europe oder so da haben wir
auf jeden fall dann angerufen und hat
noch einer übrig und halten dann hier
angekommen bin habe ich ihn gefragt so
ähnlich wäre verständlich dafür drei
jugendliche irgendwann haben wir uns im
markt gegeben und die kostet einfach nur
2 1000 eurem vormacht normal gebildet
zwei schlecht dass wir das jetzt günstig
bekommen haben dass auf jeden fall die
ganze insel
ich hab euch die werden ja auch immer
also das jetzt weil sie so der eine
bereich der schon gesehen diese tür
wir haben hier wohl regelungen
temperaturen und weil wir nicht im
hotelzimmer bin ich eigentlich ganz
immer direkt länger als ein wenig
überfordert haben wir unseren kleinen
content allen anderen tagen über dann
ihre hintern
die beiden foto nicht wahrscheinlich
dass ich ein sehr großer kunstkenner
wenn wir haben beispielsweise wo man die
häuser von einer staffeln helfer ersten
ich habe das sehr lange studiert und war
auch zwischenzeitig dozenten und einer
der anerkannten universität
hier haben wir unseren teil abfragen ihr
wieder auch schon dass der verpächter
für eure jacken reingehangen vor dem
gipfel hat mit meinen liedern
neben den kleiderschränken haben wir
ihre weitere kleiderschränke und wir
haben wir tatsächlich auch noch ein
kleiderschrank und wenn er dann anfang
haben wir minibar
wir werden direkt oder der verbrauch auf
den orangensaft
ich habe hier vorne durchlaufen der
normale reisende konsultiert der ernte
einbringen kann aber bei den jüngeren
größer war der erste raum von diesem
hotelzimmer im ganzen haus also hier
habe ich die welt hier habe ich einfach
ein paar wochen hin geschnitten rahmen
wette und da wo max spielt es gerade der
balkon das heißt wir haben einmal hier
in balkon und davon haben wir auch noch
einmal kommen da kommen wir gleichen das
jetzt unsere haut ich zeige euch das mal
eben gegangen wird also nach vorne haben
das hat unser andere bekommen da vorne
darf
what were you galt am leben hier
von joe cocker wohl dann trocken
ein start
flowers mit
frank appel hallo hier bin ich
verschaffe dir noch eine stunde
ja genau in die proben wäre okay danke
danke danke für diese arbeit noch
vergessen habe ich extra gesagt werden
da oben wurde brauchten wir auch
vorgebrachten anbringen lassen damit ihr
was und raumfahrt haben weil ich finde
man morgens das frühstück radio hört
dann wenn wir aufhören hier ist dann das
heißeste schlafzimmer leichter auch nach
hause
wir haben ja nicht auf muss jetzt nicht
auch machen ich mache trotzdem haben wir
laufen bald mal mein gott immer sehr
genau das ist jetzt weiter willkommen
hier kommen wir hier in unserer
vollkommen mit keramik von keramik her
die mit dem teuersten panik mit namen
hier übrigens sechs stufen
fußbodenheizung übrigens auch wichtig
für den standard
[Musik]
toilette wir haben alle dusche wir haben
hier noch eine badewanne und hinter wir
sind die waschbecken und das war dann
schon mit unserem ersten hotels haben
noch fünf weitere lange gebucht aber die
sind habe ich nicht so erwähnt werden
noch mal ganz kurz das vorhin war
natürlich alles nur spaß also wir sind
dankbar dafür dass dass wir hier sein
dürfen wir haben uns wirklich nur
gedacht wer am tisch sind spontane
aktion wir konnten jetzt nicht mehr wie
noch in der wohnung mieten wir das durch
am gleichen tag allgemein nicht
funktioniert deswegen haben sie einfach
in verbindung mit dem modell gesetzt und
wir haben natürlich nicht den kompletten
preis der bezahlt aber es ist auch keine
produktplatzierung oder werbung die
haben auch nicht verlangt oder so aber
wie ich dachte mir einfach ein cooles
zimmer und es deswegen hat man youtube
channel und jetzt zeige ich euch nochmal
in so einem kleinen hotel vorn ein paar
teile diese hotels beläuft
[Musik]
leute das war jetzt auch hier mit dem
video wendet euch gefallen hat das gerne
mal da ist jetzt da oben ein smiley
eingeladen abwickelt main kanal kosten
und abonnieren und hier unten findet ihr
ein weiteres video verlinkt gern mal
schauen